after more than eight years of
on-and-off cease-fires and being forced
from their homes many times these
refugees seemed unfazed by turkeys
announcement of a five-day pause in
fighting the war in Syria has shown them
time after time peace is never assured
mother Liz Mejia
this life is not called life anymore
it's called destruction if anyone says
I'm alive what he should really say is I
am dead in the last five days
the UN's international organization of
migration has screened more than 2,300
Syrian refugees smuggled into Iraq
refugees say they have no other option
because Kurdish fighters in Syria are
preventing them from crossing the border
we are Syrian but we hate our country we
don't want to go back nedra and her
sister each paid a smuggler six hundred
dollars she says she and her two young
children walked for five days I was
alone in the desert everybody left it
was just me and my children I was
suffering this latest wave joins the
more than 1 million refugees and
internally displaced people already here
in the Kurdish region of northern Iraq
the government says the international
funding it relies on has been cut in
half it's affecting its ability to
provide basic services such as food
water education and health care
the influx is only adding to the
financial pressure
the French Foreign Minister met the
president of the Kurdistan Regional
Government on Thursday and pledged about
11 million dollars to alleviate the
humanitarian emergency it's very sad
actually this is too much
we hope the warring parties will get
together and talk about peace again and
exercise maximum restraint again none of
the refugees we spoke to are thinking
about returning they've lost all hope
that Syria will ever be the home they
remembered before the war
Natacha guy named al jazeera - Hook
province in the Kurdish region of
northern Iraq